by the time I've done my scam I'm
already gone now you're the lead guy but
there's some other people involved I
figured out how to get Social Security
to issue Social Security numbers to
people that didn't exist that's crazy to
me
Brandon green Michael White Lee black
reservoirs oh yeah you always think
you're clever until the judge is looking
at you going what are you doing I
created banks satisfy the loan on a
house and I applied the loans at all the
lenders at the same time and they all
lend me money so it was easy $400,000
you made I got your high school
transcripts I got everything I then go
in the DMV I get a driver's license I
got a house I got whatever I want who's
at fault here
they'll be arresting me as Garry
Sullivan the male prostitute the male
prostitute it's a homeless guy he's
blowing guys for 20 bucks a pop I don't
know if he's got a driver's license I
know it's horrible I feel bad not
judging me are you at this point Hardy
hardcore alcohol drugs rock and roll or
no this chicks a maniac we got had four
thousand and a double bag we're spending
money like you can't believe the FBI was
waiting to catch me everybody had given
me up I mean I'm too cute to go to
prison this is not gonna work out well
for me
I know it's coming down I'm just gonna
pull out two or three million dollars
and I'm leaving that would have been it
you think so nothing's changed
it's so right for fraud did you ever
think you would make it take sweet
victory I know this slice
yeah why would you bet on Goliath well
we got red tape now you came in given
values contagious this world of
entrepreneurs we can evaluate this happy
run homey look what I become I'm the one
[Music]
my guest today's got a special story and
let me tell you why I brought him on
board this is a man who in two years
figuring out ways how to fraud the bank
he made eleven and a half million
dollars eventually he was on America's
most wanted list
secret service specifically FBI was
after him three years they couldn't
catch him eventually they caught him in
2006-2007 he got 26 years
he just got out six seven months ago
July of 2019 and he's got a book out
called shark and the housing pool on the
run with the Secret Service's most
wanted list having said that my guest
today Matthew Cox Matthew thanks for
coming out sure no problem
so this is you gotta you got a crazy
story here man what's what's the story
with you learning how to go up against
the banks and you know make eleven and a
half million dollars in two years and
some say forty million some say other
numbers so how did you even get into
this business see how did I get in the
business I was I graduated USF with a
degree in fine arts which is essentially
you know I don't want to say useless but
I couldn't make any real money doing
that I have a learning disability I
tried I actually tried my hand at being
an insurance adjuster got my two twenty
property casualty license in Florida
became an insurance adjuster was laid
off twice that industry was not working
for me I had a girlfriend that had
gotten a job working for a subprime
lender and she said you're made for this
you've got to do this you absolutely
would be phenomenal at this and the nice
thing was all the paperwork was done by
the processor so all I really had to do
was get clients bring him in structure
the deal and most of the paperwork that
was processed by the processor so it
worked really well like the first month
I think I closed like I closed like like
a couple of loans next month was like
for loans and it was six then it was
eight then it was 10 then they made me a
branch manager eventually but within a
year so I opened my own mortgage company
so you left them I left them who were
you with that first it was Eagle lending
it was a legal limit yeah well they went
under yeah well a lot of them do yeah
some of them you remember like you know
there was big names that you would
remember yeah so Eagle ending this is in
Florida well this was in yes this was in
Florida but they were in several several
states okay and so a year later you
decided to start showing deal right and
what happens next I hired a bunch of
brokers I had probably a dozen guys
working there and the problem was it at
Eagle essentially sorry essentially at
Eagle lending very really a first loan I
ever did everything looked great except
for one piece of paper which was a
verification of of rent my client or my
my borrower had a 30-day late my manager
told me get rid of the 30-day late you
got a loan you'll make thirty five
hundred bucks if you send this to
underwriting the way it is you're done
mm-hmm so she actually pulled out a
bottle of white out and gave it to me
said white it out make a copy so I made
a copy I mean I was - I'd never done
anything wrong before made a copy sent
it in sweated bullets for four or five
days went through underwriting
everything's great loan clothes I got a
check for 3500 bucks you know it in
Bolden me and the next guy if he had
made fifty five thousand dollars he's
going to get a loan but he made forty
five so if that four became a five we've
got a loan well I changed the W - you
did that over there or you started doing
it I started doing it at Lynette Eagle
oh I'd ego net Eagles but then when I
started my own place it just it just
ramped up and before you know what all
the guys working for me are doing
fraudulent loans and we just became a
you know a mill I'm not saying all the
loans were fraudulent but a good portion
of the loans were fraudulent loans when
you were doing it at your place can I
ask you a question about Eagle sure when
you were there let me ask you this
because sometimes in the world I was in
LA and when I was in LA I mean
countrywide new century you remember do
you remember these guys yeah guys are
making full five hundred six hundred
thousand dollars per month is what
they're making and it's no income no
assets creative financing you know don't
worry about it everyone's got a seven
twenty seven forty all this other stuff
some of the guys that did it right came
from a place that taught the right
habits
some of the guys that picked up the bad
habits came from a place that was very
normal to have the bad habits would you
say you picked up some of those bad
habits from being that eagle or even
prior to that you kind of figured out
some creative ways to make money even as
a kid in high school or coming out of
high school yeah I know I I really
didn't it was it was definitely at at
Eagle and it started with the with my
the manager of the store and she was she
was making money she was closing loans I
was desperate to make money I was
desperate
not to end up living in my parents spare
room and and I just slowly it just it
just started creeping up on me before
you knew it it was just all-consuming I
mean I I you know and and look I enjoyed
it that the fact that matter is is that
you know getting over on somebody on the
on the banking industry on an
underwriter and kind of faking them out
or something it there's a certain I
guess perverse pleasure and that you
know you start if you feel good you feel
smart you feel sharp like wow it really
did something the loan closes you make a
chunk of money and it just it just it
just got bigger and bigger expanded from
there and of course my brokers are all
doing it now and and there's so many
people in the industry subprime was so
corrupt at the time even when we got
caught and we got caught all the time I
got caught with a couple million dollars
from a bank one time talk to the guy
it was um Pinnacle Bank Corp out of
Chicago talked to the owner
he called me up he's like look we've got
clearly this is fraud we pulled all
these files we got a couple million
dollars they'd already sold a million to
household bank and I'm sitting there
saying look if if you're trying to tell
me that you want me to buy back two
million dollars that's not gonna happen
so we need to come up with another
solution here and he goes okay well
nobody want look here's nobody wants the
FBI digging through their files here so
we're gonna go ahead and sell this
million to household in a in a in a sale
next week so if any of them come back on
us just promise you'll help us get rid
of them of course
the likelihood that they were gonna
catch that fraud two months or three
months later was it was very unlikely so
of course that sold in and I mean I got
called multiple times it eventually
you know eventually a broker that had
worked for me got caught and committing
fraud and she wore wire she and her
husband wore wire on me
because they knew I had been doing fraud
and they got me to admit things on you
know on tape and so the FBI came in they
they said look we're going to indict you
and so they indicted me well they did
actually I've waited a night it doesn't
matter you know essentially they they
said you plead guilty to this fraud and
you lose your mortgage company and so I
said okay I mean by that point I think
when the FBI came in which was at a
later time they said that the mortgage
company they they estimated it had done
it like 40 million in bad loans over the
course of like two or three years but
that doesn't mean that that's loss just
means that you got a two hundred
thousand dollar loan that you shouldn't
have gotten mm-hmm and they're saying
that's a bad loan that's two that's two
hundred thousand dollars and bad loans
well you made the payments or maybe you
didn't I don't know but it's about they
estimated around forty million so at
that point at that point I you know I
should have claimed bankruptcy should
have moved in with mom and dad but I've
got I've got bills I don't want to take
a step back so I decided to go ahead and
and escalate the fraud and I decided to
start flipping houses in an area of
Tampa known as bore City Tampa Heights
area I don't know if you've familiar
where it's a nice area yes at the time
it was rough it was rough I mean the
median house the median house in that
area was probably worth fifty to sixty
thousand dollars
God so I go in and I start buying up
houses the problem with buying those
houses is that the people that live in
those areas don't they don't have good
credit
they don't have their down payments you
know they quit their job a week before
the loan closes and so you're struggling
against your buyers so what I decided
was that if I could get around the buyer
somehow to borrow the money against the
houses which which meant I had to start
creating the buyers so I started
creating my own buyers and creating
synthetic identities and I figured out
how to get Social Security to issue
social security numbers
to people that didn't exist and and they
were ready creatively yeah it was it was
it was you know I want to say it was
difficult but it was it was really a lot
of phone calls they were just coming up
with the documents and it wasn't it was
complicated but it wasn't once I got the
system down it wasn't that hard it
Social Security will issue a Social
Security number to a child under the age
of twelve twelve months old without the
child being present so all you have to
do as the parent is show up with the
birth certificate and the shot record
and you say my child was born I never
got a Social Security number issued and
they'll issue a social security number
to a child who's ten months old without
seeing the child and of course I would
go in using a fake ID and they would
check the computer they go you're right
this child exists but we don't have a
social security number for him we will
issue the social security number they
mail it to you so then I would go with
that social security number I would then
order three secured credit cards make
the payments for six months and suddenly
I have six hundred and 690 credit scores
you know six fifty seven ten credit
scores so I've got this perfect
synthetic individual that can now buy my
houses for forty grand so I'm buying a
house for forty grand the problem is I
would clean it up a little bit and even
if I sold it at top dollar for sixty or
seventy I'm making 30 grand 25 grand
it's not worth it
so that the issue is you need to borrow
more I need you to borrow more money in
this synthetic individual name so I need
to get the houses to appraise higher so
I was dating a girl at the title at a
title company and she explained to me
how how sales were recorded and of
course do you know anything about
appraisals you probably know which part
well I like to appraise a house yeah of
course I know would oh yeah right
you need an appraisal well the way they
gauged the value of the home is they
look and they find three other
comparable sales in the area within one
mile with that sold within one year and
so what I did was I said okay well if
I'm trying to sell this house for 150
thousand I can't get an appraisal unless
I can find comparable sales and she
explained that look if you pay the extra
doc stamps on that on the sale those
recordings will not go for they won't
record at 50 they were recorded 150 or
200 if you pay an extra seven hundred
dollars
it adds a hundred thousand to it so now
I'm buying houses for fifty and I'm
recording the value at 150 or 200 and
I'm doing it all over the place in the
name of synthetic and intimate
individuals don't exist and this was the
dumbest part is that I'm naming these
guys
James red Brandon green Michael white
Lea black yeah
Reservoir Dogs just I mean and I thought
it was so clever I really did you know
you always think you're clever until the
judge is looking at you going you know
what are you doing
you're just suddenly you're always okay
that was a jackass move my bad but so
I've got all these houses and these guys
buying he's buying five houses we're
recording the values for 150 to 200
thousand the appraisers the banks are
I'm ordering an appraisal from the bank
countrywide is coming in and saying
they're their own appraisers coming out
and they're they're looking at they're
going yeah it's worth two hundred
thousand there's a comp two blocks away
here three blocks over here they don't
realize I own all those comps in various
names I'm creating the market can I go
back on a title when he said you pay
$700 a little bit more the comps are
going to favor you who helps the benefit
the comps for you is there somebody that
puts bigger numbers who is that person
what happens is a lot by your house for
50,000 okay and I close obviously a
title company that I know okay person
and then I either would say I want
attack I want a construction credit for
a hundred thousand dollars
added to this fifty thousand our sale so
now they would say well that would make
the sale 150 thousand Matt it's going to
cost you an extra seven hundred in taxes
and I would say that's fine I'll pay the
extra seven hundred because it's point
0:07 for every hundred thousand seven
hundred bucks so okay so it's noting
that the title represented so fraudulent
you just inks gonna cost another hundred
thousand dollars on construction alone
0.7% seven hundred bucks it's $150,000
on it's not a $50,000 or even if I
bought it from you for 50 and I
explained to the title company let me
record it I'll bring it down there and
record it and they go if they know me
they're like okay well why well I want
to get a copy of the recorded deed okay
no problem Matt I go down I fill out the
paper I change the paperwork right then
I just add a check for $700 I recorded
it I go to the clerk here you go they go
okay 150 oh okay it's 200 you added an
extra
$900 hmm jumps up almost 100 and instead
of a hundred thousand 140,000 plus the
50 now it's 190 mm-hmm
so I'm doing that and so the whole
market shoots up through the roof it
goes from like the a medium price of
60,000 to like 190 to 200 I think by the
time I was done they said it was at 250
so but all these guys are buying five
houses so James read owns five houses
worth two hundred thousand a piece that
he bought for he's got two hundred
thousand I'm borrowing a million dollars
on these houses so I'm borrowing a
million dollars on houses that I've got
maybe 250 and another hundred thousand
dollars to clean up a little bit I'm
making six or seven hundred thousand
dollars for each one of these guys and
there's several people involved so this
is what this is what we were doing this
there's several people now you're the
lead guy but there's some other people
involved correct I got now let me ask
you if you don't mind let's go back to
when you started your own mortgage
company until you had that issue when
you start your mortgage company what
were some of the forms of creative
financing that you guys were doing
because I've I've heard many different
forms what were some of the ones you
guys did you know the thing is a lot of
people talk about the liar loans yes you
were mentioning the problem with the
liar loans is that you dip eclis the
person still has to have decent credit
you come on no income no assets right
yeah over 720 or 680 right so if I've
got some guy that works at tire Kingdom
who's got a 590 he's not getting a liar
loan but what I can do is I can get him
a subprime loan if I can prove his
income so we would change his w-2s and
pay stubs to say he made enough money
and we would fake his down payment
so I created banks online I created
banks I would make a website that said
Bank of Ybor and you could go to the
website and looked at it looked like a
legitimate small bank and I had bank
statements and so if the underwriter
asked for the bank statements because
you need to prove that you had the your
down payment in the bank for 90 days so
this guy who works for Tire Kingdom has
bad credit and been at three different
jobs in the last two years we would
either
fix his credit sorry fix his w2 so that
he made enough money or we would say he
worked at a place where he didn't work
but we said he worked there for five
years and some friend of mine owned the
business and would say that now I'd come
up with a w toothpaste dadada they would
verify his employment then his we would
verify his his down payment was in Bank
of Ybor well there is no Bank of Ybor so
if they said well we want bank
statements okay we'd send him I had
original bank statements I'd color bank
statements they look perfect we send him
the underwriting if underwriting called
to verify it someone would open would
answer the phone bank of Ybor help may
help you sure hold on let me get you
Jennifer yeah we'd get on the board
internally working for you no no there's
no banker no no I totally get it but the
person that would answer this is Bank of
Ybor they're in your office yeah we'd
answer banker that's why I'm saying yes
okay and back you know they're typing as
if they're checking to see if this guy's
a real guy okay they faxed over a
verification of deposit if they have to
it it seemed very legitimate to
countrywide who would then lend a
hundred ninety thousand dollars on a
house that was worth 40 we maybe put 10
into it so you know you end up making
100 to 150 thousand dollars for each
loan and this guy's borrowing a million
dollars like this so we're making a
chunk of money so so the other party
said the the would he call it white out
you know the whole white out thing which
was very big I mean that's what you did
with Eagle right right learn the one
time doing what about it just do
wide-eyed unchanged it a it was forgery
there which you white up with the
signature and there was what you just
did right now what you talked about
there was many different creative
methods to getting financing done what
were some other methods that you you
know maybe you guys that are heard about
that was very unique that you don't
quite often hear out there in the
mortgage industry you know the stuff
that I did is so it's just so it's so
over the top you can't it's like one of
the things I did was to get obtain
financing was I would satisfy the loans
on my own houses so I buy a house for
two or two hundred thousand it's got a
hundred and ninety thousand dollar
mortgage
I'd create a false satisfaction of a
false satisfaction and you you know when
you when you borrow money from Bank of
America and you get a mortgage on your
house and it gets paid off you paid it
off
how does public records know it was paid
off Bank of America sends a satisfaction
of mortgage saying hey you know Patrick
borrowed $200,000 but he paid it off
here's the satisfaction proving he paid
it off and they record that and now it
no longer exists it's there but anybody
who searches the title can see that
there that mortgage has been satisfied
does that the question is when that
document arrives does anybody ever call
at public records does anyone at public
records call Bank of America to verify
that they mailed in that document and
the answer is no till today
till today as far as I know faraman I've
talked to a couple title guys it's a
couple years ago I talked to a guy that
in prison that worked at a title company
said oh absolutely not nobody's nobody's
verifying those because it's a recording
system so what I would do is I would
borrow money two hundred thousand
dollars on a piece of property then I
would create that a satisfaction of
mortgage from the lender let's say
mortgage warehouse for instance so I
create a satisfaction of mortgage from
mortgage warehouse and I've done them
from everybody Bank of America Lock
oviya countrywide son trust tons of them
so you I would then go downtown I'd say
hey man listen they mailed me this but I
called them and asked them what it was
they said they were supposed to mail to
you and public records would say oh
you're right this happens sometimes and
they would go ahead and record it and so
the document gets mailed back to the
person that created it well of course
that's countrywide but they don't know
there's there's just forty thousand
countrywide addresses out there probably
not probably let's say four hundred they
don't know they don't know where their
mailing it says return to sender
countrywide and then it's got an address
well I just give an address to some
vacant house so they'd mail it to a
vacant house I go a couple days later
and pull it out I've got it it's
recorded now when I call the lawyers
title and say hey can you pull the title
on my house to see if anything shows up
they pull the title and they go yeah you
don't have anything on your house does
the mortgage show up no there's no
mortgages great I then turn around
go to SunTrust Bank or whoever I want
and I say look I need to borrow two
hundred thousand on my house they order
a title their title comes back and says
nothing's uh nothing's on no no title on
your nope no mortgage on your house
great I need to borrow two hundred
thousand dollars that you're sure no
problem they pulled my credit they lend
me the money I borrowed the money I
borrowed a million dollars like five
mortgages on my own personal hot
residents like a million dollars on a
house that honestly wasn't worth two
hundred thousand borrowed my bar at one
point was it it was it nine hundred
thousand nine hundred thousand in a
house another one I borrowed four or
five hundred thousand on a few different
houses that were only worth the me a
hundred got three or four mortgages on
them just by satisfying alone or by
doing shotgunning which is when you
satisfy the loan on the house so that I
don't owe anything on this house I
probably do but I satisfy the loan so
what I do is I turn around I go to four
different lenders or five different
lenders and I apply for loans that all
the lenders at the same time they all
search the title for the house there's
nothing on the house there's no mortgage
showing up on the house and they all
lend me money
well they mail in their documents so
when they arrive to arrive on Monday one
arrives on Tuesday when arrives on
Friday all the clerk does is recorded to
record it they scan it shows up they
scan it they show it doesn't matter if
there's five different mortgages showing
up it's not illegal the clerk isn't it's
not her responsibility to say hey this
is odd there's five mortgages on this
house the point is is that every closing
I go to I walk away with a check for one
hundred fifty thousand so now I've
borrowed six hundred thousand dollars on
this house that's worth 150 or 200 and
it's called shotgunning so now I've got
six hundred thousand I deposited in the
bank I pull out all the money with any
month or two I don't even have to make a
payment because I just take off because
I probably did it in somebody else's
name or some of some fictitious person
I've done that when I was on the run I
did that over and over again so it was
easy for hundred thousand dollars you're
making oh yeah it's like a million I did
1.3 million did nine hundred thousand
one time but at four hundred thousand
when I took off on the run I I had I
always say this I had no money I had
about 80 grand but to be on the run with
80 grand that's nothing the way I was
spending money at the time so I went
straight to Atlanta I've got like four
hundred thousand dollars I
rented a house satisfy the loan borrowed
400,000 pulled the money out of the bank
took off but I didn't part of my name
obviously there's a fictitious no the
this this is a pretty crazy stuff I want
to get a little bit deeper into it but
let's go back to the part where you're
getting socials under the age of 12
you're going in here's the idea you give
the fake ID yes we see it then they send
you to social to an address that you're
staying I'd use the social you go get
five credit cards then you're building
credit you go to six eighty seven twenty
then you go get a house the ID that you
use to get the social is that a fake ID
that you're using
initially it was that I was using fake
IDs but then it fairly quickly I
realized it was easier just to get the
DMV to issue me the driver's license no
real light no real idea for the kid
under twelve years old under two hundred
twelve months old well keep in mind when
I create their their credit profile I
don't put the age of a twelve month old
or a ten month old kid I put that he's a
34 33 year old man well even if it shows
up even if it shows up in the credit
profile when they pull it fraud alert
social security number just issued
issued within the last year you know
what happens you know many times I've
been there when somebody's pulled it and
they've looked at it and they've gone
that's weird
there's a fraud alert here really what
is it you trust me if you're in a bank
using a fake ID and they got that the
loan officer says to you huh that's
strange that's not something you want to
hear I mean it's taken everything in me
not to just bolt out of the door I'm
already terrified so I'm sitting there
and then you've got the loan officer
going huh that's strange and I go you
know what is it and they're they're like
it says fraud alert and I'm like really
and they're like yeah Mike huh well what
why and they go well it says that your
social security number was issued within
last year really that is strange this is
your social yeah you've got my two years
w-2s they go yeah that is strange
oh and they go well and you've always
used absolutely
you've got my driver's license they're
like yeah okay yeah
that is that's weird okay so anyway they
just keep right on going I'm never once
had a loan turn down because how many
times has this has happened a few times
two or three times two or three times
this is out but they could have done
anything they could have they could have
called
I think there's US citizen gov which
verifies your so state of birth and
everything else they they could have
done anything they no they just went oh
man I have so much documentation and
there are lots of fraud alerts that come
up every time you alter your name in any
way it says fraud alert because it'll
say Matt be Cox Matthew be Cox fraud
alert two different names got it or you
know em Cox it fought alone well this is
the this is the date of birth and it
doesn't really have it it just says
issue recently it doesn't seem right
because I pulled his credit and on the
credit report yellow although it does
say fraud alert issued but then it also
says that his date of birth is 1971 or
1969 so that doesn't make sense so they
disregard it right away because you're
sitting there in front of them and I'm a
clean-cut guy and I don't appear to be
nervous or leaving so I have all the
right documents and you need to talk to
your loan or your boss or whatever we
need to take get this taken care of
let's get going yeah I'm good thanks
they just keep going I've had that
happen much time so so when you're using
when you get a social for a kid less
than say 10 months old it's a fake
social that you're getting when that
when the bank gets the social on there
and the bank runs credit and credit
comes like or even a credit card company
MBNA you know Visa MasterCard American
Express whatever ones it is when they're
due to social they're not checking how
old the person with the Social Security
is I mean no I mean they're no well let
me get two straight so so I can write
out the application myself and I can say
same name everything's the same as a
social right and I use that 10 month old
kid social to get a credit card but I
can put age 34 but on here to get the
social these 10 months the creditor that
gives me the credit card for $500 or
$1,000 or $200 they don't they don't
have a way of verifying whether this
person fictitious characters 34 years
old or 10 months old know what hey first
of all you know what I miss I understand
what yeah well there's two different
areas here one is let's say Matt Cox
myself let's say I wanted to suddenly
start using a different social security
number okay I would have an issue
because I already have a credit profile
sure these guys don't have credit
profiles Lee black does not have a
credit profile
there's no Lee black so I take Lee black
a fictitious name I take an address I
take a date of birth and a social to a
ten-month-old and I run all of that I
slip that board and it creates a new
profile that they that there's no
disputing information too now in the
public records they hey say hey there's
some guy out there named Lee black he
was born in 1970 he's got this Social
Security number and he's got any applied
for a visa and he lives at this house
now maybe the visa says no we're not
they deny him because he has no credit
well then they say but you know we will
do mr. black will get give you a credit
card if you'll give us to 103 bucks
right John 5300 whatever yeah so I give
him the three-year crystal-blue the
credit with that absolute right in six
months in six months if I get two or
three of those in six months I've got
700 credit score's I did it over and
over again well Matt what I'm asking for
is the creditor the bank when they run a
credit on you with that social that you
put 34 years old
we Equifax Experian strands Union they
don't report back the H that matches the
age that was put on the application now
there's no way for them to verify with
Social Security other than to know that
the social security number was recently
issued and there's only one of the three
agencies that even checks and they'll
say hey this was recently issued in the
worst case scenario they'll they'll do
is say can you send us a copy of your
driver your driver's license that's
crazy so you make a copy of the drivers
rest you know how many times they would
say we're not they would pull the credit
and they'd say hey this is a this is a a
like a UPS box right but you have a like
it let's say you go to UPS you get a
real address but it says box number 200
and they would say hey this is a UPS
store and I would say no it's not and
they say well give us a give us a water
bill and I say sure and I give him a
water bill with a house address and they
go well that's weird we have this listed
as a UPS okay yeah and they still mail
it you know it's a UPS box you're
mailing it just
I gave you a utility bill they they have
little things that they asked for people
just if you're really saying it's a
residence they don't want it they want
to mail it to a residence in not UPS box
then they ask you for something if you
can provide it you're good they just
mail it and I'm making the payments for
so long and then something happens the
guy gets into our card you know how many
times I had guys there three or four
houses are going to foreclosure the
mortgage companies are writing letters
they're writing letters saying that
they're going to do that you're going to
put you a collection we're gonna
foreclose I would make a copy of a five
car pileup where somebody had been
life-flighted out and I would make a
copy of it I'd retype it and I put my
guy's name in it then I'd write a letter
with a copy of that from his sister
saying he's in critical condition the
doctors say even if he comes out of the
coma he'll never work again you might as
well just take the house they stopped
coming around I mean most people they
stopped paying and they run it I would
stop paying but then I confront you and
say this is the reason this is what's
going on I say hey I'm thinking about
going to bankruptcy I'd write a letter
back they just they just go away
most people take off and that makes them
think something's wrong but if you can
say the kid mind you if they called
their employer their employer says no
he'll no longer works here
they don't just stop answering the phone
he doesn't work here anymore didn't they
get a letter saying he was in and up he
was in a car accident
so and of course they're gonna sit
they've got a reason so they go away now
we understand what happened
he was an accident it happens he lost
his job it happens they go away so and I
feel bad about that I see you did you I
sees no ID on your face you know I'm not
worried about you I'm not I'm actually
not processing it the way you think I'm
processing it look I run a company and
for me we're designing a software it's
technology right now we're putting a few
million dollars into it but it's all
about creating rules so guys can't beat
the system it's this isn't about this
isn't about what you're doing you know
like for me listen I mean obviously what
you're doing is Roger now you want to
did your time twelve years and for you
right you did your crime and you got the
punishment for right that's what the
you break the law you get caught you're
gonna go to jail just kind of the system
works just like in the financial
securities you're gonna lose your
license get terminated get fine you know
all this stuff that you got to do but
I'm just wondering how kind of a system
is it that somebody can run a credit and
it's not gonna tell the bank that is
trying to get financing from TransUnion
Equifax or Experian that this client it
just got their social and the date of
birth is you know 7 10 2019 rather than
7 10
you know 1990 it's a big difference
between that you know so but all they
know is it was issued within the last
year and they think that could be a
mistake must be a mistake
he's got three credit cards the person
that thinks this must be a mistake how
much is that person getting pays that at
$35,000 year person yeah okay I got it
yeah thank him and probably makes money
based on loans he knows I can get this
guy alone is there a fraud alert but I
can get him along got it with if I just
overlook that so I'm gonna overlook it
because it doesn't make sense so yeah
you know ears ago best buy one away from
Commission's they stopped paying
commissions on their sales guys because
they weren't doing customer service it
was just kind of like a cutthroat and
customers are kind of feeling like it's
a little too competitive
right so they want to a different model
I think Nordstrom's did it I saw this as
well at one point they wanted more to be
hi man how are you how's everything I'll
spend a little bit more time talking to
you sure it's a house family everybody
good yeah what can I help you with okay
I'll show you on so they paid a little
bit more salary but no commissions
because their motive was they don't want
to be the cutthroat environment
sometimes certain people you don't pay
commissions to like those types of guys
that are positioned that way where they
are willing to get the loan to go
through that's a guy that shouldn't be
getting Commission it should be just
you're doing your job is what you're
doing and your job is more to play
defense and to play often so the common
structure for those guys I don't think
is set up properly okay so now let's go
back to where you are you're now you
know it's thinking about one of the
things you asked me when was a creative
financing was one of the things that
people do I'm sorry I just dawned on me
what my brokers would do is they would
say that the guy was owner occupying a
property that he was an owner on
so if I'm buying an duplex
I can get 80% financing from countrywide
if I because it's an investment property
if I say I'm gonna live there I can get
ninety five to a hundred percent so I
all you have to do is your borrower says
he lives there so I remember one time we
did not once that we did this multiple
times remember one time we must have
done eight different loans at one time I
still remember the brokers name that did
it but I'm not going to say his name but
he did 8:8 owner-occupied properties
duplexes all at the same time with eight
different lenders for one woman and her
husband was a sheriff's deputy and one
time I think we did six loans for also
duplexes owner-occupied and for a
realtor for a big-time realtor in
Brandon Brandon's outside of Tampa we
did that a lot where and one time we did
it and two of the loans got happened to
be like on the same credit line so one
was a big bank which was like Washington
Mutual they had done they they had their
credit line was a smaller company we
didn't know they were it was just an
extension of Washington Mutual
essentially they were using their credit
union so Washington Mutual ended up with
two of the same loans so they ended up
calling the broker and saying look we
got two owner-occupied duplexes what's
going on she comes in my office she's
like oh man we got a problem and I'm
like what's up she's like this guy he's
a lawyer for Washington future all he's
threatened to sue me put him on the
phone I get on the phone we talk a
little bit it's called the FBI and you
know I tell him look you don't want to
call the FBI who knows who was it your
company that might've been doing
something wrong I don't know what this
just what my broker is doing let's
figure this out so he lets us refinance
it they actually discounted they gave us
a short pay you know you know a short
sale yeah but short you know so we'd
have to pay them the whole 95 miles they
drop it to like 80 something because we
couldn't get the same type of loan they
took a huge cut and they paid my broker
a commission to refinance the loans and
they sent her flowers when it was all
said and done it was it was I've at
that's in the
I remember was so funny I mean it's not
funny it's horrible but it was like
shocking because he just had us over a
barrel but they didn't you know they
just want to they just want to pass just
let's just get through this and move on
let me ask you rates being so low when
you were running and and mortgage boom
was crazy were rates anywhere near where
they are today
no nothing no no they were they were
still there were five six seven percent
yeah so so so look the problem was way
higher
so subprime is even higher than that so
prime was way higher than that yeah
they're at least at least a couple at
least 200 basis points higher so if it's
the rates five percent it's seven or
seven and a half yeah eight or nine but
I mean what do I care I'm only gonna
make a few payments so for you as a
completable yeah so how much how much of
your sill was to a real customer how
much of it was just pure market
manipulation and and and putting
packages together you mean when I was on
the mortgage guy yeah will you actually
having a lot of real loans coming in oh
yeah yeah but it was I'd say let's say
it's let's say it's 5050 I mean we had
look we were I was an FHA approved
lender you know we were doing we were
doing conventional FHA approved VA
approved I mean it it it was a part of
it was a legitimate company but the fact
is if you had a pulse and you walked in
my place you're if you walk in that door
and you had a pulse you were getting
alone you're getting you're getting a
little get applause unless you just
unless you decide notch if you come in I
want this house this is what I want this
is what I could I'm gonna get to that
house got it I'll do whatever I gotta
got it how much are you how much is your
legitimate income coming in at that time
I mean I may be 40 50 percent and what
would that look like five hundred grand
a year me yeah oh no no I'm not making
it is this Tampa Florida this about 15
years ago Tampa so what a granny oh yeah
okay 202 I got to underground so you
have a good life you're not making
because you said the loans are 50 grand
100 grand hundred 50 grand you're not
doing there's not there's not there are
a couple new two hundred thousand two
hundred fifty three hundred thousand but
there's not a lot and are you getting
correspondence at the back end on the
back end or not at that time
yeah we're getting quarters of a point
we're getting a yield spread that they
call it yield spread it's
it's like 1 or 2 points you get hey
listen when I first started you get like
2 or 3 point I really got down to the
point where they they were like this is
just too much they were doing one or two
they didn't need to do it and they felt
like they had to do it and and it was
getting even more money coming in got it
now let me ask would you consider
yourself a better salesperson
or more at a deal maker what would you
consider yourself I mean I I think I'm a
good salesperson but I think like I had
a I wrote a story about a guy named
Vitaly and vitality Rana basically like
a boiler room type of the situation
where it's just high pressure lots of
high pressure you know he they they push
and push and push until you close and
that's not my style my style is more
it's more value it's more this is why
the product is a good product this is
why you need the product this is this is
what it can do for you you know and you
need to make a choice and if it's not
forget it I'm not gonna I'm not
interested okay I totally understand
that I wish you the best of luck I hope
you do find the product that you want
and we move on maybe I call them back in
a couple days maybe they call me back
maybe it's it doesn't work out at all
but I'm not a high-pressure guy it's
more like you have to believe in your
product and you have to know the value
of the product that's that was more my
sales technique keep in mind that in the
mortgage company it's it's this is what
we're charging this is why we're
charging it and if you think you can go
to Bank of America and get a hundred and
thirty percent LTV loan that doesn't
exist by all means go but they're gonna
throw you out you're coming right back
here you know and and of course they are
coming right back and they when they
walked in the door
like I said fifty percent of them
roughly already knew they had an issue
they meant someone got it
somebody directed them to me so were you
more deep paper or we actually doing am
bees as well we were doing a and B we
were doing you know like that FHA
approved we were doing conventional
loans we were doing I wasn't doing those
we had certain brokers that enjoyed like
doing those it literally if I you came
in and you had all of your Docs and you
were this perfect 750 perfect
documentation client it was like okay
call Susan I'm not this is not for me
I'm not interested in doing this loan
you're gonna argue about the interest
rate you're gonna argue about how much
what my broker fee is you're gonna
nitpick about you know the home
inspection and you'reyou're a problem
I'll take the guy from tire Kingdom or
Walmart that knows he's been beat up
he's got some things in his credit and
he thinks I'm Superman because he's
thinking this guy can do anything
I've already been turned down my two
banks no way I'm getting along I've got
it that makes sense well what do you so
you were saying right now you're doing
the scriptwriting you're doing all that
other stuff can you right now work for
somebody else or no can somebody hire
you and start selling or no sure yeah I
can I can work for someone absolutely
I've been offered jobs I just can't like
like I said I can't move I'm I have to
stay in Tampa um you know my my mom
she's like listen she's 90 years old
she's in a home I had lunch with her
I've breakfast with her four days a week
I typically have dinner once or twice a
week
I don't live very far from her and like
I said I mean it's I just can't I was
offered a job in Seattle I've been off
our jobs are in Los Angeles I got a
buddy that is in it wasn't Atlanta when
he offered me the job but now he's
offered me a job in Nashville
like I can't go you know so I haven't I
have to stay in Tampa cuz I went long
cuz you know yeah she like I said a
minute ago he she she came and this is a
woman that came to see me every two
weeks the entire time I was down through
breast cancer through a stroke
my brother would say mom you're sick
maybe you shouldn't go this week and she
would say well I'm sick but we're going
and he'd say well well you know you get
so tired she goes oh well then I'll
sleep in the car we're going so you know
I you know like I said I've been enough
of a [ __ ] of a son that the least I can
do is hang out you know as long as I can
as long as necessary so you know moving
is not an option
if I have to live in someone's spare
room I got to drive a piece-of-shit Jeep
well that's what's got to happen that
I'm hanging out as long as I can in the
meantime I write synopses I write books
that's that's what I'm doing to get by
so it you know it's it's an issue but
you know I'm making it work
mama could pass a zero judgment too you
know
oh she loves me she's cheap yeah she's
she's a she's good yeah she's she's good
how was she when you were growing up how
was your relationship with her I know
you were send your dad you know three
months is good then he goes on two weeks
yeah and and then he goes back to being
normal again how was she when you were
growing up I mean she was she's a rock
you know everybody thinks their mom's
the same you know but she uh yeah she
was she was the glue that held our our
entire family together when she's
talking is she telling you hey you know
Matthew is she telling you how you'd be
good please don't go back and do it
again or no it's just relationship
conversations life nothing when I guess
they're not yeah yeah just curious like
she uh I'm you know she said you know
it's it's always you know you know she's
you know you always hear about the
Jewish mother right
you know but the Catholic mother's just
as bad you know it's the oh you don't
have any you don't have any collar
Church I'm like no mom I have collar
shirt you don't wear them oh I'll wear a
collared shirt next time you know she's
like you know oh so you're not shaving
anymore we're growing a beard is that
what you're doing you know I'm shave
Alice do it well next time so next time
you'll be shaved yes ma'am I will be
shaved next I might god it's constantly
what are you doing for work oh you're
you're painting okay okay and that's
working you're selling those I mean
she's a you know and there's money and
I'm selling books mom I got Barbara in
the books there's money in that it's not
a lot of money but she's uh yeah she's
she's awesome
that's cool that's cool can so long-term
you want to be in the world of writing
books and do turning those into
documentaries movies that's what you
want to do long that's what I want to do
I listen the average writer on the
street is constantly trying to get to
the guy
that are in prison to get to the good
stories while I was in prison I got four
and five guys a day coming up to me
telling me their stories it's a good
good way of putting right so the gut
they can't get it they've got to write a
letter they got to ask him to add them
to their core links can you email me can
you write me a letter back my guy just
has to meet me in the library tell me a
story and so every day I'm hearing
stories that I'm like look you got a
drug story I understand what happened I
know it's [ __ ] up but I've got like
six of those stories and it's just not
there's nothing unique about it or you
didn't steal enough money or it's not so
I'm looking for unique stories that are
over the top or just extremely unique so
they're worth writing it's worth
dedicating two or three months to write
a synopsis plus I have all these guys
there I've all of their documents most
of these guys are fighting their case so
as opposed to some guys sitting down
with me just telling me the story and
you like a reporter you can bare verify
a little here and a little there
I've got your entire I got your I've got
your um your indictment I have your FBI
interviews I've got the police reports I
have the transcripts and I can verify
everything I know what you're saying is
true that gives you more credibility as
a writer when you write it and they're
gonna have more interested in it more
interested in right hopefully who are
you in high school
oh I'm just troubled I was kid I've
learning disability my dad was an
alcoholic I mean it was you know what
will you use selling weed will you need
a guy after you in the game ever you
know ever you'll drop or point oh GPA
guy were you you know I was see I was
getting C's and I went to a school with
about 25 kids in it for five private
kids with learning disabilities and I
end up graduating they're fairly Evans
with C's end up going to college and got
a degree in fine arts and said USA USA
yeah it did great in at USF but you know
like I said when I graduated I just
don't that much I could do in the
business world but who were your like
meaning
did you have a temper were you not good
with authority did you get pissed off
with your dad did you have a falling out
with your dad did you have a point to
prove your
screw the world what what happened what
which one were you know I mean I
definitely wanted to try and get respect
from my father he was a a big influence
in my life but he was an alcoholic he
was a he would go on binges like two
three week binges and then he'd be sober
for three months and be a great guy but
he was belligerent
he'd my mom used to call him he give you
a tongue lashing he wouldn't spank your
anything but and he'd talk to you like
you were just a dog so you know and you
know and I've got like about a learning
disability I've got I go to school with
very little kids and they're only a few
kids they're even close to my age
they're spread out throughout Tampa so I
don't really have a lot of friends so I
mean it's it's you know I would say I'm
I was a troubled kid but I wasn't
getting in trouble I wasn't not a drug
guy now
never never into drugs really yeah I had
a lot of girlfriends okay so you would
will you a party guy or no no not really
just girlfriends just girlfriends sports
I'm five foot six that's not a lot no
baseball second base there's no sports
at the school it's got 25 got it got it
and movies music what's your inspiration
like what are you reading are you a you
a not reading anything I've got a
learning disability I'm watching TV I'm
watching movies what are you watch some
movies you know that at that age what am
i watching gosh I'm just curious like
what's stuck with you like what inspired
you are you rocky guy or you a you know
Godfather guy or you know I'm gonna
definitely have seen all the Godfather's
off and you know obviously who hasn't
was there a character like men I like
this guy because this guy gets away with
everything which is something I would
say all of that I'd say happened when I
was older it became crime movies I loved
you know I the score I loved sick movie
huh really great movie matchstick men
you know catch me if you can the heist
you know grifters I mean you know those
types of my god blows make sense love
those movies were you a yeah what was
that the story of a Hughes were you
Howard Hughes guy or no IIIi did seen a
movie and but were you fan of his or no
you only from what I saw from the moon
okay
so catch me if you can I mean that's a
six story with you know to to be a true
story and eventually FBI hires them to
help them catch the guy
right when you watch that were you like
wow this guy didn't get away with
anything he was amazing it was amazing
so to you he was an amazing story yeah
how old were the first time you watch
that how old was I was I in my 20s 21
felonies yeah so was there a screw the
bank they already have so much money I
don't give a [ __ ] about the bank was it
you know the hell with these you know
people that are doing countrywide
they're already screwing people anyway
so what's wrong with me making some
money what what was there any of that or
no you're just kind of like I'm just
trying to make money to have fun I want
to say is a combination of one I listen
no scruples at all about taking money
from the bank I had no problem I didn't
see that saw it as an institutional
crime I didn't see it as hurting anybody
and you know there are people that will
drastically disagree but what I stole I
felt like was was a pittance you know so
I I had no problem at all with it you
know and listen to me I'm like I said to
be honest it's it's a huge thrill and it
does it it absolutely you know made me
feel like I so I mentioned this to sorry
in the book I was let's talk about you
you feel like James Bond you walk into
the bank and you provide them with fake
ID Social Security card fake w2's fake
pay stubs and they're calling you mr.
black the entire time and then they cut
you a check for $250,000 you walk out
the bank and they thank you for being a
great customer I mean you you that's
that's that's double-oh-seven stuff I
mean you feel amazing I'm walking I've
got fake passports I'm walking through
customs mr. Carter mr. you know
so-and-so and they're looking at my
document these are state these are
issued by the US State Department going
in and out of the country with a
different passport so it's it's an
amazing feeling you know I do it's the
thrill of getting away or is the thrill
of making them look like an idiot I
think it's I think it's getting away
it's definitely getting away with cuz
I'm not around for anybody to look bad
so I'm it's getting away with it and
this is the thing about the money too is
that I'm not a flashy guy like I never
do I never had a Lamborghini I didn't
wasn't driving a Porsche I'm driving a
40 or 50 thousand dollar sports car and
I'm perfectly happy I'm not flashy
I don't want didn't want a bunch of it
engine I want a pretty girlfriend and a
decent vehicle and that's it even when I
have a million dollars in the bank I'm
driving a fifty sixty thousand dollar
truck I'm not trying to drive a Ferrari
it just wasn't my style I'm not looking
for the attention are you running are
you running with a crew like are you
partying with a group of you is it
well by the time by the time I start my
own mortgage company we have a fairly
tight knit group and everybody's kind of
you know they all know you've got
Realtors you've got a group of Realtors
you've got a couple appraisers you've
got some underwriters that you're
dealing with I bought an underwriter a
he wanted what do you want we were
giving him a couple to $300 every time
alone went through we ended up giving
him he worked for a United capital
lending I think we gave him I got him a
compressor like a a gay guy it was a
silver compressor with like red interior
I thought it looked horrible he said I
want this car you get me that car you
make all the payments you give me the
car he said everything you have goes
straight through it did to us it was it
was a good six months so everything you
put it's gonna be able to provided it
looked right like me he's getting any
certain to look change this called the
appraiser Jim he's fixing and he's like
saying to me now is anything happen
through when you go cut or no I I when
you went down did a lot of people go
down or no no because what what happened
was when I took off on the run because I
was on the run for three years so while
I was on the run the FBI was waiting to
catch me so they're investigating but
they're really waiting to catch me
because everybody's just going to blame
me so they're thinking if we catch Cox
now you can't blame Cox because we're
gonna give this guy we're gonna threaten
to give this guy 50 years he's gonna
give up everybody so you guys are all so
these guys are giving me up as on
they're talking to them they're all
saying it was Matt I didn't know it was
Matt I didn't know so they're thinking
when we grab him and listen when they
grab me they had a stack you know FBI
302 SR that's the the name of the
interviews that they get they could be
is a 302
I had 302 forms and I have mo I forms a
Memorandum of interviews from the sea
service and I mean I had a stack
everybody had given me up of course most
of them had given they'd given me up by
covering themselves yes I did this but
Matt had told me he told me this so I
didn't know so I did wasn't aware of
what he was doing so yeah sorry I was
just crazy crazy stuff when you're on
the run for three years are you at what
point did you know you're on the Secret
Service wanted list I got what point
wasn't like okay oh my gosh these guys
are really after me oh yeah I had I'd
gone to well when they came to get me
was it was a sheriff's deputy that came
and told me look
the FBI's formed a task force well there
was a task force formed by the FDLE for
the Florida Department of Law
Enforcement they handed to the FBI there
was already I'm already on probation
remember I told you I got I had lost the
mortgage company I started this huge
scam went for about a year and a half
two years got eleven and half million
dollars or borrowed 11 a half million
dollars we're all making good money but
suddenly on like a Thursday this air of
Stephanie shows up and says listen I
used to date this chick on the works for
Tampa PD he was with Hillsborough County
he said she came to me because I'd done
a bunch of loans for him came to him in
the morning
early one morning like six o'clock in
the morning said look your buddy Matt
Cox is going to be an arrest in the next
few days I worked on a task force we
just handed it over to the FBI they're
gonna rest in the next couple days so he
tells me that on a Thursday so I have
literally an hour left in the day and
the whole next day did get out as much
cash as I can because I'm thinking I'm
leaving
I'm already on federal probation the
judge is not gonna be happy so I'm
definitely going to prison I can't go to
prison look at me I mean I'm too cute to
go to prison this is not gonna work out
well for me so I mean I've seen
Shawshank I know what happened so I'm
ready to take off so I within uh within
a day or so I get like 80 grand out in
cash this is one you were talking about
right so I go straight to I'm got this
girl with me named Rebecca Hulk I had
been dating her a couple months I barely
know her
she
desperately wants to come with me she's
in love she's wonderful everything's
great and she was she held it together
pretty pretty well for a couple months
and she knows what's going on oh she
knows 100 old guys got it
and so we take off I don't realize that
she's bipolar she's not taking her meds
she's within right word I'm gonna out
before we start we're at each other's
throats she's nuts so I get 80 grand out
we take off on the run we go straight to
Atlanta we rent a house i satisfy the
loan on the house I borrow about
$400,000 I pull the cash out of the bank
it's funny because why would you was
thinking a minute ago I just think of
one of the stories I was gonna say to
tell you was that uh one time I had gone
to Kay I was cashing checks for like 84
like 8,000 9,000 under the $10,000 and
so at one point I got a check for like
29 grand I think man this is ridiculous
you know I'm sick of this we're going in
here and here's gonna take another month
so I said I'm gonna start cash and
larger checks and she's like that's what
they don't do it and I said no it's okay
I'm gonna cash it so I go in I had
stolen a guy's name by the name of Scott
cogno and I had gotten an Alabama
driver's license issued to him so I have
a real ID I have a real social Real ID
everything's real so I go in the bank
give him the cashier's check that had
been issued by the title company when I
refinance the property I had him issue
the title the checks in two different
guys names
what larger amounts one of them was 29
grand a lot most one were eight or nine
thousand one was 29 so I go in I said
hey my name is Scott kono I need to cash
this check they go well that's odd and I
was like whew okay they said why don't
you put in your bank and I said well
because my banks in Florida they're
gonna hold it for who knows how long
this is 15 years ago so they go doesn't
make sense and I go well you know this
is a cash transaction bank you can give
me yeah we do largely okay let me tell
me let's talk to manager manager comes
out he says okay he said what's going on
I said look I need to cash the check and
he was okay so he takes a check of my ID
and my credit card he leaves and I
remember Becky the girl I was on the run
with she calls me up she's calling what
are you doing I go on what's taking us
so long with the guys being in the
cherokees he's wait he's doing
verifications and stuff I don't know
she's like okay well if the cops show
outside call me and so I hang up we wait
we wait guy comes back and he goes okay
mr. mr. Cogan I have a question for you
said how did you get the check issue to
you and I went well it was issued a guy
refinanced his house and he paid me the
check okay why and I went well not that
you know there wasn't any of his
business but it wasn't a hard question
so I'm like I'm trying to alleviate the
his anxiety so I said well I'm I'm
adding an addition on to his house and
this is part of the draw and he was like
that makes sense and that's make sense
and it was all right he was okay he
leaves five minutes later she's still
calling what's going on I don't know
he's got my stuff he's we get out of
there no I can't he's got my stuff I
can't leave hang up he comes back he
goes um what are you gonna do with cash
like oh are you serious and he goes well
I'm just you know it's it's I feel
apprehensive about this and I went well
I'm gonna cash a lot of the guy's checks
we give them checks and they don't have
bank accounts because you know they just
don't they're laborers and we're gonna
cash some of their checks and he goes
okay that makes sense
leaves comes back finally comes back and
I said hey what's going on you know and
he says listen he said I just were just
doing a series of checks on to verify
things and it okay and he says uh I said
what are you doing is what we're trying
he said
we it turns out the dish check was
issued by on a house owned by a Michael
Shanahan and I was like right right and
he goes he said right so we're just
trying to verify that Michael Shanahan
issued the check that's all well there's
a real Michael Shanahan and I'm thinking
oh my god huh well that's not good and
I'm like okay okay so he leaves Becky
calls what's going on here they're
trying to call Michael Shanahan she's
like get out a bank no like I can't this
guy's got my [ __ ] I leave the bank for
sure they're calling the cops I have to
wait hang up the phone
a minute later my phone rings I look at
it I don't recognize the number I pick
it up and I go hello and there's a woman
like hi this is Kimberly from SunTrust
Bank is this Michael Shanahan I'm like
yes it is
and she goes hi we have someone here at
the bank trying to cash a cashier's
check that was drawn on your on your
from the title company and I'm like okay
and they said what would you
was it how much was the acknow for ya
the mascot kono is thirty about $29,000
even I think and she says that's right
mister thank you very much mr. Shannon
said how did you get my number because
if you called information you would have
got his real number and and I go how'd
you get my number
oh we called the title company they
looked on the application that I had
filled out and I'd used the cell number
and they said we just got it off there I
hope it's okay no problem no problem ok
thank you boom hang up the phone five
minutes later still the guy comes out
with some woman counts out the money to
me gives me the money I stand up and he
says Mr kono I would like to say that I
feel very uncomfortable about this
transaction I said well what is it
exactly because you know I can't put my
finger on it
I said well it'll come to you and I walk
off listen I was terrified [ __ ]
terrified I like to think that when the
Secret Service showed up you know five
six days later a week later he realized
wow so you leave
oh you're attached like four hundred
thousand dollars we had for one thousand
and a double and we leave but we're
spending money like you can't believe I
miss radicular going to Jamaica we're
going to burn you know we're already in
hardcore yeah we're going to Las Vegas
this chicks a maniac she's nuts I mean
she won't I literally had to make her I
threatened to leave her three different
times I think I put two in the book she
calls she begs I'm sorry Mike you've got
to see somebody you I get her to start
taking Zoloft
she takes it for about a month she stops
taking it she doesn't like the way it
makes her feel she goes nuts yes she
gets the cops called one day on me two
o'clock in the morning it's I mean
listen I was a hostage situation I mean
I fit was I this is the Becky girl yes
she was over-the-top just insane ma'am
are you at this point
partying hardcore alcohol drugs rock and
roll or no you spit under control not
you it's not me okay my father's an
alcoholic I don't drink I don't smoke
at all ever so you're not doing control
you you have control right now not
because you're not have a control issue
I'm young
no I've got some I got listen I got
major problems I'm a narcissist
antisocial I mean how got some issues
are you July July 2nd your what's your
birthday yeah July said your license
your birthday yeah narcissus and would
you would you consider yourself
pathological liar as well or no no you
wouldn't put yourself there no
absolutely not to be able to face some
of these guys and stayed that yeah no
natural like there's a there's a fine
line there's books written about
sociopaths that they can just look at
you and tell you would you say so you're
somewhat there or no wellness animal a
sociopath what I'm saying is I'm not a
pathological liar or pathological liars
tend to Tyndale they feel good about
lying they they lie it's impulsive they
almost can't control it yeah some of
them there are different versions of
pathological life I wrote a whole book
on a guy named Marcus shrinker who's a
pathological liar and so I've read I've
read multiple books on the subject and
studies and he's clearly a pathological
liar what's the difference in your eyes
pathological liar sociopath what's the
difference well most almost pathological
liars are always pretty much always
sociopaths so you could be a sociopath
and not be a pathological liar how is
that well a sociopath is just someone
who has it they are not basically you're
like a stick of furniture to me they
have almost no empathy at all no
sympathy for anyone no well that about a
pathological liar someone who can't
control his ability to tell the truth
he's impulsively just lying he enjoys
lying it's a thrill out of lying out of
fooling you my lies are simply designed
to acquire money and move on I'm
actually a matter of fact a lot of the
articles if you read the Atlantic one of
the couple of the different people that
they talk to in my case they said the
thing is in cox's in Matt's personal
life he's extremely an honest person
it's only when it comes to running a
scam so if I'm running a scam of course
I'm gonna tell you what I need to tell
you to acquire what I what I want but in
my social life I'm not I'm not gonna lie
to you there's nothing no tell you the
truth this is what's going on you'll
deal with or you won't
so sociopaths to you is is there's no
emotion yeah your stick of furniture
you're not I don't I wouldn't say
emotionless I mean Atlas there's very
varying degrees of everything there are
people that are are schizophrenic and
they happen to have a little bit of
paranoia on
or to small subjects then there are guys
that are extremely delusional they just
see things that aren't that they're hear
things that they believe things that are
just outrageous you know so there's
always varying degrees the moment you
came in you look paranoid from the
moment you stepped in you were paranoid
oh we I cuz you keep mind how this all
occurred I literally got a couple emails
and I had seen the program and I seen
the same same of the bull and I'd seen
the other one a part of another one I
watched the whole whole thing which we
talked about the guy with the Michael
Franzese yes yes yeah which was great he
was great
and so it happened very quickly and it
was like okay there was next thing I
know I'm walking in I mean I I think
like I'm CIA or do you do when you came
a little bit because I didn't I thought
at some point we would somebody would
say hey talked you know asked me some
questions you know at that like crazy
yeah of course I thought there would be
some kind of a setup instead I didn't
I'm walking here I'm still waiting like
okay well at some point they're gonna
sit me down and say okay well here's
what we're here's what we know
here's what we're gonna film and here's
a instead I walk in and it's and it's
like sit down I know everything about
shop and then Hawk is over here to your
right
yeah the intimidation it's a little
shocking Wow
okay my question would be do you think
today are we set up in a way where a
Matthew Cox of 20 20 March 20 20 can be
prevented from happening or a Matthew
Cox of today can still do what you did
in 2006 no I think that's funny because
I did a another podcast I did a podcast
and the guy and there the comments are
outrageous but a lot of the comments are
oh this could never happen this could
know it nothing's changed
you know that there haven't been not
like there's all these public records is
still recording listen in New York they
have a huge rash where people are simply
just there finding people's properties
that have no mortgage on them at all and
they're trance
the deeds to people - - they're like
they're doing a quitclaim deed to
somebody that like a buddy of theirs and
then they're selling the property out
from somebody cuz it happens to be some
abandoned house it's in decent shape
they'll get access to the house they'll
get an appraisal Nilsa I'm gonna
transfer the house from this person -
you record it
nobody's contacting the original owner
nobody's caught it's a recording system
so you know that those things are still
happening
satisfying loans that still happens in
the way that I did it the combination of
the way the combination of scams that I
I used was unique so every time I did it
they very quickly zone zoom then you
know or connected it with me so which
ones can't be done today I don't know
that any of them couldn't be done other
than the fact that borrowing the money
is more difficult but it's not
impossible the only difference is most
of these loans now instead of changing a
w-2 typically they're having you sign
what's called an 88 21 form and they're
sending it off to the IRS to verify your
employment so they're saying you said
you made 75 thousand dollars last year
you didn't that's a lie they're doing
that now there's a lot of most-most
mortgage companies how much it costs to
the bank to do it it's almost free oh
it's free they don't send it to wisely
and all of them do it it's it's more
paperwork and it's and I think if you're
mailing off if if you're mailing off ten
thousand and one's coming back bad is it
really worth it I mean mostly even the
bad loans a lot of just pay yeah but I
give you an idea on the insurance side
on the insurance side there's something
called the Nexus right so where they
check what medication like I can check
if you say I'm not on any medication and
I'm the insurance company underwriting
you right I can go through a testing
center that the you know reporting place
that can send me an email back and say
no the math you take Soloff is on you
know prozac and he takes this this he
takes blood thinner these are the things
he's been on for the last six years all
right then I come back on like wait am I
can't give you preferred underwriting
right but that testing costs me 25 bucks
right to pay to that reporting agency so
on the insurance side sometimes people
don't want to do it because they don't
want to pay 25 bucks times 10,000
policies it's a quarter million dollars
a month of a cause that's thirty million
dollars I can keep that dream
dollars and put it for underwriters but
you're saying on the mortgage side
there's no cost to it finally IRS the
IRS so I'm not sure that the IRS they
are would in every bank do it IRS did
not use to charge do they charge now I
don't know you don't I don't think okay
so let me ask you this other question
let me ask you to set the question this
other question is which part of the
things today I know you said some of it
like the IRS of verification so if it's
not being fixed today and it can't
everything you did can be done today
if all of it can be done today who's
that fault here meaning you know it when
you're in the sales world the processor
wants it to be funded just as much as
the loan officer does right right and
whether it's the title the appraisal guy
making 450 or titles making a thousand
seven hundred two thousand dollars
depending on the side alone there's a
lot of people that want to get this loan
to be funded right the only person that
takes the hit is when wha will realize
China's no longer buying their paper on
the back end and they shut it down and
one who goes from being a 330 billion
dollar company in oh five to being sold
to chase for one point nine billion
dollars so really the only person that
takes a hit on the back end is the one
that can't sell the paper kind of like
that one guy that the two million
dollars they sold a four million right
and they come back but my question is
because there's so many people that have
had their hands in the candy jar like
everybody's getting a piece of it does
anybody want all of this to be stopped
and if yes who well I can't imagine
first of all I mean fraud just they love
to throw like the numbers it's three
billion dollars or trillion dollars okay
yeah but overall it's it's it's very
little it's the percentages it's not
even like one percent is for all I mean
it's it's so minor it that that why
would you spend all of this money when
the actuaries have already accounted for
a certain amount of fraud so if we know
there's gonna be a certain amount of
fraud we account for it what is the real
incentive to try and fix it it's a
marketing loss the way they would look
at it right for mobile marketing loss
right what what's the big deal we're
good we're it's really not hurting us we
can commit and complain but the truth is
it's really not damaging and it's more
of things more true I think it's more
trouble to put up all these all these
regulations
over-regulated right now a lot of these
individual people are gonna get hurt the
people that actually need the loans
aren't gonna be able to get the loans
because we're trying to stop all this
fraud but the truth is the fraud really
isn't harming us as much as it it is as
much as people think so flip the coin
FBI hires you okay and they say come on
in we want you to help us out we want
you to catch the modern-day Matthew Cox
would you know exactly how to catch all
of them would it be trends that you can
but there's not by the time I'm by the
time I've done what I I'm doing by the
time I've done my scam I'm already gone
how do you detect that scam unless you
want to revamp the entire this guy's are
greeting those tough to kind of leave
and be gone right that's the biggest
temptation of a scam artist because he
can't it's always the next hit is the
last I'd like the movie Carlito's Way
right we said well you know babe this
the last one I'm doing and we're gonna
go and live over there even listen even
I have even I have the same thing
I was on the I was on the run three
years Dateline was coming out mm-hmm I
just been in Fortune magazine had just
done a piece on me so I was in bloomberg
businessweek
did two pieces Fortune magazine there
were thirty some-odd articles in the st.
Pete Times Chicago Tribune ditto that's
the whole time I'm on the run so I know
it's coming down and I know that
Dateline was about to come out and I'm
ready to go I'm leaving and I'm thinking
I'm just gonna pull out two or three
million dollars and I'm leaving and I
don't make it to that let's say I had
gotten I like to think that would have
been it do you think so
I like to think so but you know what
let's just face it almost every time I
did something that was it because you're
greedy or you're overconfident look I'll
tell you tell you one time one time I go
to I'm on the run I was on the Secret
Service's most-wanted list by the way at
this point
mmm-hmm what year is this oh six or so
obviously oh oh four no no no this is
this is oh five I'm gonna say this is I
think of the mortgage industry or four
or five right I had gone to Las Vegas
with Becky okay we at this point I'm
surveying homeless people to get their
information but I've come up with a
survey form that says we're surveying
homeless people to get to determine
where where we're going to place our
next homeless facility I work for the
Salvation
Armie I've got a little badge I know
it's horrible I feel bad so stop judging
me so they have no they have no idea
they're good for twenty bucks they're
filling out the form I order all your
all your stuff I got your high school
transcripts I got everything I then go
in the DMV I get a driver's license I'm
driving I buy a car in your name I don't
even need that you know I know of course
I go to Social Security I get a Social
Security issued so I've got clean Social
Security I got credit I got a house I
got whatever I want in your name you're
some guy that lives under a bridge in
Los Vegas now I'm in South Carolina I
remember the guy this is funny because I
would be the guy and said the guy had
gotten in Las Vegas I meet him while I'm
doing the survey I asked about does he
have any a criminal record
he says he's got several arrests for
prostitution but they were misdemeanors
I said okay he's a my real I go so
you're a male prostitute he's like yeah
I was like okay whatever so I take the
thing I go to South Carolina
I go to DMV I get a driver's license in
his name I then go buy two houses and
then after I buy those houses I satisfy
the loan in his name satisfy the loan in
both those houses I then go to multiple
mortgage companies and I borrow money on
the houses one of them I borrow like
three four hundred thousand the next one
I borrow like close to a million dollars
on the house their house is only worth
two hundred thousand in the bank I'm
cashing checks I'm pulling out four or
five six hundred thousand dollars over
the course of a few weeks Becky by the
way the whole time every time I would go
into a bank this didn't all the time but
a lot of times she would say what
happens if you get arrested and I would
say if I get arrested they'll be
arresting me as the guys name was Gary
Sullivan
they'll be arresting me as Gary Sullivan
the male prostitute the male prostitute
they will not run my prints right away
because my identity is not questioned
back then they didn't have the scanners
so they're gonna run they'll go scan
yeah but it doesn't necessarily run it
through a 'thus so that's a new thing
they're doing the scanners now right
what they didn't at the time they had
them but it wasn't they weren't I said
look the worst that'll happen I get
arrested it'll be a minor charge get me
a lawyer get me out on bail we'll take
off she goes okay
so I go in the bank one day I go into a
walk oviya I'm waiting to get cash a
cheque for like six grand and I cashed
pulled out 50,000 60,000 under that
account I had like eight accounts well
next thing I know BAM a cop walks up
with a grabbed me from behind they
arrest me they walk me in the back I'm
done that's it I already know I mom so
Secret Service is most-wanted list
this is it they take me back they sit me
down all the customers are looking at me
guy says mr. Sullivan we're waiting for
the detective to show up I'm thinking
detective okay that's like FBI or
something I guess he's coming well then
this cop comes in and he says hey I'm
with the Richmond County Sheriff's
Department we understand you know we
Wachovia fraud department called us they
said you're running some kind of a scam
you're pulling out cash I go are you
seriously owes you know I said look man
am i under arrest he's like no I said I
feel like I'm under arrest and I show
him Michael my constant go take those
off it takes them off me they call the
Wachovia head of security he's on the
phone he says okay now what's going on
he's borrowed how many loans because he
said you've got three loans on the house
I actually had like six they only caught
three and I said okay I said yeah is
that illegal and the guy goes do you
know I'm not really sure I remember
right then thinking I'm walking out of
here I got just got to convince this guy
I haven't done anything wrong while Kobe
is telling him I have done something
wrong
but if I can get out of here so I start
arguing with him this guy saying he's
got all first mortgages I'm saying
they're not all first mortgages Wachovia
is first mortgage - they know they lent
me a first mortgage I said and who are
the other ones any I go and he goes oh
SunTrust and so it's over right SunTrust
is a credit line the other one is a
second mortgage that's the three and
he's like well why did you he wants to
know why you brought him took out all
that money half a million dollars on
$200,000 house I said bro I don't know
how it works I work for a labor company
I give my business card I said all I
know is I came here the woman I told her
I needed half a million dollars the loan
officer said I can get you this much I
got a friend over here she can get you
this much this much it sounds to me like
they got a problem in the bank I don't
know anything about it he says okay okay
and the guy screaming it's a shotgunning
scam he's you don't understand he's
doing this he's doing
he's like and I'm Salem and I wouldn't
know how to do this I don't know what
he's talking about and he says yeah I
don't this guy is he works for a labor
company he doesn't and he's like why are
you pulling out all this cash like a web
cache and guys checks I mean I got a
bunch of Mexican guys that doing roofs
and they don't take checks or I give him
a check I cash a check I mean is that
illegal now that's not illegal
okay so then he says uh his ID his ID
starts with zero zero zero and he goes
no it's a real ID it was a real ID he
was it's a real ID r this guy was in
California
Wachovia hmm he was no our ID start with
zero zero zero and he said uh he said
trust me I brought him through NCIC it's
him this is Gary Sullivan and I go oh
now I'm not Gary Sala by oh come on bro
what are we doing here man what are we
doing he goes I know binaries okay and
he says okay so he talks to the guy they
this guy literally is arguing with him
he eventually says okay I'm gonna take
him downtown have him fill out a police
report I'm waiting for the district
attorney to call me back I don't even
know what to charge them with if I can
charge him with anything I think you
need to talk to your loan officer hangs
up the phone I then get up when I get up
the two sheriff's deputies are there and
he says do you have a driver's license
and I said this is an ID and I said yeah
I have a driver's license I said but
it's in Nevada I don't know if Gary
Sullivan 8 he's a homeless guy he's
blowing guys for 20 bucks a pop on the
park bench I don't know if he's got a
night a driver's license
one of the cops says I'll check he goes
out to his car he comes back and he goes
he does have a driver's license and he
goes okay it's cool and he goes yeah
here's well it says he's five foot ten
and they look at me and I go with the
good pair of shoes and they all go huh
and so at the same time he says I
remember he had said something about
that's right
you're from Nevada and all the cops look
at me and they look at each other and
they kind of grin and I realize he said
he ran me through NCIC he thinks I've
been arrested in Nevada for prostitution
and I thought off the block how it was
just ridiculous so they could be my ID I
follow him to the police station when I
we were gonna say I literally almost
want to say listen man that's all
[ __ ] on my knees Mac Cox
they followed me the police station I go
in the police station fill out the
police report
I'm waiting and
hallway my wanted poster by the way is
on the wall there's all these posters my
only color one on the whole wall you're
seeing it I'm seeing it I'm pissing in
my pants when I leave Oh before I got
there when i was i fall took my own car
when i'm driving there
becky calls me i pick up the phone and
she goes oh my god what's going on and i
say i tell her what happened and she
goes you don't understand they just
raised you to number one of the secret
services most-wanted list you've got to
get out of there I said I can't there's
a sheriff's deputy behind me that the
other guys in front of me I got to play
this out and I say the works that are
happened is I get arrested you get me
out on bond shoes I'm not getting you
out on bond I'm not getting you a lawyer
she had like six hundred thousand in
cash of your month my money she was now
living in Houston and I'm like what are
you still together or no well we're not
together we're we're still changing but
we're not goodbye others yeah okay she
we hate each other so I go into the
police station fill out the report guy
walks me out I get in my car I leave I
go straight to two more banks and get
out more money until another person
recognizing me goes to make a phone call
I jump in my car and I leave so that was
like that was insane and what's funny
about that so I remember like a week
later it comes out in the st. Petersburg
Times comes out and says you know
fugitive caught in South Carolina
released by authorities and it was a big
article about how they grabbed me they
brought me downtown I talked my way out
of it they always mentioned that like on
American greed they always mention it
what a play will write about you know
six now god it was it that was a short
that was probably a couple thousand
words um were they right they just it
was they really blue they made it sound
like I was this you know like the what
was it the most ingenious you know
prolific mortgage fraud con artists of
all times and yeah is that some great
some great sound bites you know the big
thing they always latch on to is one of
the things you were asking about like
how flaw
the system let's say when I was
satisfying the loans one time I
satisfied a loan using the name C
Montgomery burns from The Simpsons
so this is so it's so C Montgomery bone
our burns satisfy the loan to like
Federal Savings and Loan Bank and I
thought remember thinking it was cute
and it was funny let me judge had no
sense of humor found it did not find it
what are you you don't like to make
people look stupid but you like to make
people look stiff you'd like to say like
look how dumb you are that you're
allowing me to finance loans on
Reservoir Dogs by Quentin Tarantino you
idiot great movie it is a great movie I
have a story with them my sister is
getting married to my brother-in-law
CEO Mac and we're sitting at home and my
sister said look you got to try to
impress my dad my dad's not comfortable
with us getting married so he comes over
he says yeah I think we should watch a
movie
my dad's a traditional Middle Eastern
guy so he puts in Reservoir Dogs you
[ __ ] back with you I mean if
you've seen the movie multiple times you
know the guys your guy now they've been
married for 15 16 years and love each
other but that's a reservoir does it I
think was his first movie that did he
put four hundred thousand dollars into
it made 14 million one of the biggest
hits story like Riera return wise and he
becomes who yesterday so at what point
do you get caught and you said it's done
when was that there was too late
November 2006 I had moved to Nashville
and Nashville like you're trying to find
the church because there's this that the
capital of Bible Bell you know in
America you go into church trying to be
Christian or yeah I'm just trying to
look I just like country music yeah so I
I go to Nashville and I buy a bunch of
houses in an area and I start the whole
thing over again I pull I think I
borrowed like three and a half million
or something like two hundred 2.5
million I forget what they say they said
three nine million I think it was only
at two point five so I borrowed some
money and I'm at that point I'm dating a
girl and she and I end up seeing another
girl and she my girlfriend ends up
finding out who I am pleads with me not
to Tilly
because I was like oh I you know who I
am I got to leave but we're living
together we're in love I think it's okay
she ends up confiding in the other girl
the other girl turns me in mmm got it
had Secret Service shows up they arrest
when you say the other glues it's like a
three-way relationship okay got it
God um so I end up getting grabbed I I
get you know it was bad I mean I knew we
knew we knew Dateline was coming out by
that point all these articles had come
out they learn about you but what you're
doing right okay Dateline did two
one-hour specials on me one before I was
arrested and then one after I was
arrested once I'd been arrested the US
Attorney came to me and said we want you
to do an interview with Dateline be
interviewed by them and they said they
consider it substantial assistance I
mean you've you've interviewed guys
before so you know a substantial
assistance you know it's cooperation
with the government substantial
assistance means you cooperated with the
government which led to an arrest or a
conviction so she told my lawyer I will
consider this substantial assistance
because by the time I get caught
everybody's already told on me
people have gone to jail there's a whole
bunch of people that haven't gone to
jail but I'm you know and I'm not I'm
definitely ready to cooperate I'm ready
listen I'm ready to do anything I got
I'm looking at a huge sentence so have
they caught you when Dateline called you
or no not yet
no no they when they caught me they
caught me and within a month or two
Dateline had eight lines episode came
out okay guy was leaving the country cuz
I knew it was coming out where were you
gonna go - I was gonna go to Australia
because if you at that point if you
showed up at on Australia with Rihanna a
couple hundred grand yeah you became
what wasn't even at that point it was a
citizen if you want it to be
fingerprinted and run you could be a
non-resident alien you were allowed to
buy property you were allowed to start a
business an imam very intrigued
Australia right so so I got a driver I
got to be there I couldn't get a job but
I could hire Aussies I could buy
property so if you show up it's just a
few hundred thousand so now you know who
else wants awestruck yeah Jordan bill
for also one to Australia I did hear
that well I did hear that very interest
obviously Jordan Belfort has been we
done a couple things figured I was on
his he was on our thing we're I telling
the story so okay so you your plan was
to go to Australia right to do that but
then they catch you here they grab me
I mean well and that's what prompted it
we were pulling out cash one of the
things that prompted a conversation
between my girlfriend and this other
girl we're asking her to cash checks get
to get us some help cos some cash and
she says what happened and so that calls
it a thing well here's what's happening
date lines coming out here's who he is
he's got to get out of country
she calls the Secret Service so we're
thinking we're all good she's thinking I
can get rid of this guy and end up with
this girlfriend so what happens is I get
arrested they swooped in they arrest me
they a few months later Dateline come
does come out it was called the thief of
hearts Becky had already been captured
Becky we had been captured already a
year before big he's already in she's
already in and she does it the whole
seeing thing is based on Becky and her
in an interview with Becky saying oh
he's a horrible guy he's manipulative he
did this he did that you know so that
comes out then the US Attorney says they
want to interview you we want you to be
interviewed and you know my lawyers like
look they're gonna make you look bad but
they'll consider substantial assistance
they'll reduce your sentence she said
you got to do it you're basically done
so by that point I go so I go and I do
the interview just before I'm sentenced
we're thinking they're gonna reduce my
sentence giving me a 5k won and reduce
my sentence they say yeah you know it's
really not enough but you said you'd
consider substantial assistance than the
US attorney said we did consider it and
it's not enough so I get 26 years I go
to prison prison prison I'll probably do
a medium security prison guys or the day
I got there a guy got stabbed on the REC
yard guys are getting beat down with
locks did you ever get beat that like
them never had a problem ever had I'll
only fight I ever had or issue I ever
had was in the low and the medium I
never had a problem within a few weeks
of me being there I started teaching the
real estate class that guy that was
teaching it didn't want to do it anymore
he was doing he wanted to do legal
so he asked if I'd do it I started
teaching it well I had a great class and
it was the medium so you could be pretty
open with what you talked about so I had
a great class guys are walking around
the compound he cost what's going on hey
man out how's it going so on
hey I mean huge massive guys everybody's
very happy you're protecting me would
they protect anyway it wasn't it wasn't
that I needed to be protected I didn't
talk to anybody if you noticed like it
was like being a non enemy combatant
like literally there's stuff going on
all around you my head's down I go to I
I go to my go to the unit I go to work I
taught GED and and then I go and I teach
the real estate class guys want to know
about certain things I'll meet you in
the in the meet you in the library I can
go over stuff with you I take we tell
take notes we do scenarios it lasts
about an hour
once or twice a week everything's great
now even some interesting cats in prison
though yeah well I was there for three
years then I went to the low okay god
right where did you start writing when
you start to writing scripts I think you
did wrote a what did you say you wrote
your own a memo right did you write a
memoir for a memoir for a guide for
Ephraim Devereaux Lee which was the lead
which was the character and Jonah Jonah
Jonah Hill place him in war dogs yeah I
wrote Deveraux Lee's a memoir while we
were incarcerated
how was he he was let me did you see the
movie of course and you what did you
think of Jonah Hill what'd you think of
the character psycho sociopath who was a
great leader and a manipulator
he made Devereaux Lee look cuddly
compared to Delta Roly Deborah Roly is
cunning super smart super smart super
manipulative super cunning I mean you
know I wouldn't trust him for anything
but you cannot you can't underestimate
him he is but he is absolutely extremely
sharp you know I wouldn't dare take that
away from him and that the thing about
him is that as vicious as he was in
business and that movie doesn't come
close
by the time I was done writing that book
you know I liked him he was he had on a
bill has an ability to get you really to
like him to you know it but but I liked
him because I thought we were a team you
know he's the kind of guy you want on
your side you definitely want him on
your side the tough guy or no he's not a
tough guy like a brutal guy he's a sharp
guy he's a does he have the piercing
eyes like you or no like you see like
that as well or no cuz your eyes are on
fire like then typically a lot of guys
that are brilliant that they think
million things in their mind their eyes
are like the way you are was he like
that is what we're no intense I would
say he's extremes very intense okay it's
very intense on all the time on all the
time okay always yeah definitely he's
definitely energetic definitely you know
he's just it's you guys still keep in
touch or no no no so good an end well
the relation I don't know he sued Warner
Brothers over the film they alleged that
Warner Brothers had gotten a hold of the
manuscript which it appears that they
look like they did there was a they sued
them they went back and forth there was
a you know there was a settlement they I
that sued Warner Brothers and Devereux
Lee we dropped the Warner Brothers suit
we sued Warner Devereux Lee we ended up
settling with Devereux Lee and you know
and even during that that in
negotiations it's extremely tough
extremely you know he's a sharp guy he's
sharp guy so I wrote that story I wrote
a story about these guys come called the
story I wrote was oxy Rush had said I
sent that to a reporter with Rolling
Stone they ended up writing an article
based on what I had written it was
called the dukes of oxy and that was
sold to New Line Cinema mm-hmm believe
it was New Line Cinema and it was
optioned you know the film rights were
sold it was so it was optioned hmm it's
been optioned they've renewed the option
several times since then
wrote a story about a guy named about a
credit card counterfeiter which is
honestly one of the most amazing stories
which is a credit card counterfeiter
named John Bozak who sold about three
and a half or
about three and a half million dollars
in credit cards to the Russian mob been
listed on several indictments was Secret
Service was after him got it's just a
phenomenal story I wrote a memoir for
him what else wrote a this guy named
Marcus shrinker that actually in 2008
when the whole financial crisis was
coming down shrinker took his airplane
up called in a distress signal the
windshields imploded I'm bleeding and
then he sets the autopilot it's supposed
to go out over the Gulf and he jumps out
faked his own death it's been everywhere
the huge story and he ends up landing
and then three days later they catch him
because the airplane runs out of gas
about a mile or two before it hits the
Gulf because he didn't account for the
fact that the door was gonna be open so
it burns off a lot more fuel and it ends
up crashing into like a swampy area and
guess what that whole plane was just
destroyed
but the windshield was still intact so
they know immediately not in the plane
the doors open I mean he thought it goes
down the windshields gonna implode when
it's the anyway they catch him so I
wrote a book about him pathological liar
that's a phenomenal story I've written
about about over a dozen almost 20 how
was a guy like you didn't do good in
school such a good writer why are you
writing I mean I know I had a lot of
help listen you got guys in Coleman that
are locked up guys from NASA you got
lawyers you've got you've got guys with
180 IQs I mean these are brilliant guy I
write that guy's in from NASA you got
guys in from absolutely there are
they're amazing guys that are in there
listen I'm not saying 90% of them are
just drug dealers low-level drug dealers
but there's a whole slew of guys that
are super sharp lawyers doctors I never
go to the doctor you just you just go
find dr. Iglesias and he's in you know
b3 and you say hey listen doc my knee
it's killing me and he does a little
exam there and he says okay you're you
need to stay off it for two weeks and I
can't go to the doctor if Coleman these
guys for like piays nobody will hire on
there so so you don't get the top of
your field and end up working for the Bo
P that's just not how it works like
sense so yeah so so you just got outta
nine months ago ten months ago
yeah be eight months seven OMA how you
feel being out what are your plans now I
feel good I mean I've got I've got a
website with all my stories on it how
are you making money right now I'm
working as I've been hired to write a
biography by a lawyer it's kind of a
vanity project super amazing lawyer I've
got two other books that I'm supposed to
write I've got I'm selling books on
Amazon so that's some money mm-hmm you
know my bills are low listen here's one
thing I learned is I don't need a lot of
money I'm stay I'd say extremely humble
I live in someone's spare room
I Drive a piece-of-shit Jeep I spend
virtually no money my whole thing is I'm
writing the stories I want to be a true
crime writer I want to get them turned
into documentaries into films no one
desires to go back to old house
absolutely not 100% no temptation listen
you know you never know what am I
supposed to say the factory oh listen I
told my probation officer I said I'm
gonna give it a year and if things don't
go well I'm gonna come we're gonna
commit a massive massive fraud I'm
believe in the United States because
that's where I thought you told them
that oh I told her she listened matter
of fact she even told me this is [ __ ]
horrible because she even told me don't
mean basically she didn't say it but she
basically said stop mentioning me in the
podcast look I don't want to be famous
stop it so I mean you know and she's the
nicest person she's extremely strict
she's concerned she's concerned but the
truth is things are going too well for
me to [ __ ] out at this point at this
point listen at this point I've got I've
got documentaries that are about to be
made I've got a series that is supposed
to be made supposed to go to Los Angeles
on the 18th and 19th I'm to meet with a
you know with a production company that
makes films for for Netflix and Hulu
they have like four of them on there
right now so things are going well the
low interest rates doesn't turn you on
right now it does nothing
pause nothing for me mother let me ask
you this just from your experience how
long can is low interest rate rates last
how long can it last this is all fake
money right now I mean I you know I was
just thinking every time I'll see like
some etrade cámara like like one of
these these
just like you know they're doing the
mortgages you know over the internet or
something I just look at things it's so
right for fraud that's why I'm saying
that it's you know but it's so ripe for
fraud yeah you watch my show what's your
first thing you thought when you saw
make sure you like yeah I kind of knew
this was all the things are the pictures
great right so what'd you think about it
you said I know listen in the big short
yeah do you remember when they come to
Florida
you make me quarter they meet with the
mortgage brokers that are like oh I'd
focus on like strippers yeah those were
my brokers those were my guys if you
want to know who were who worked for
Mack you sales used-car salesman those
guys right there there's my strippers
there they're nut jobs they're going to
conventions were just like that
phenomenal conventions I went like I
mean you know it was it was outrageous
and those idiots
those were the brokers that I hired I
think we're good you didn't have to be
that that great so you know especially
if you can go in and bring me the
documents I got all these documents
these two need to be changed and I
change them you gotta loan you did you
watch accountant would Ben Affleck the
now isn't being as that what is called
the accountant no no well you got a
watch I missed a lot of movies but well
you got to watch this one I bet that's
right you just got out seven eight
months ago
go watch the accountant and then tell me
what you think about the accountant some
tells me you may like it I don't know if
you watch it's a very would you agree I
think is the you may you may like the
movie it's an interesting story tell us
about the book before we wrap up here
shark in the housing pool tell us what
this is about it's that's the story of
for me basically it it's a brief account
of you know it's a memoir it's a memoir
tell a little bit about my my upbringing
the what influenced me slightly it's a
look and then it gets straight into all
the fraud in the mortgage company and
then it's me on this life on the run the
scams it's it's extremely I don't look I
think it's super interesting
of course I'm I'm biased I wrote it so
but everybody that reads it loves it
it's a phenomenal story you you've just
gotten bits and pieces of here's what
the client says so you just did this
kind of contradicts what you said
he was not some boring banker type in a
gravy flannel suit but a hip young
daredevil who was who were expensive
clothes drove flashy cars and loved to
skydive that's that's what they say you
know that they always hype it would you
drive you said a truck what were you
driving
I mean I've driven every thought driven
mercy I've had Mercedes I know Lambos
Ferraris Porsches no no it's too flashy
I'm I'm a now action gangster did you
watch America against or no yeah I think
I love you know exactly seriously well I
mean listen it obviously today's story I
told it's gonna be a crazy story and I I
was in the world with a lot of friends
our mortgage that would do modification
remember one modification care that was
a whole opening for more fraud to be
taking place but if if you if you
haven't heard a story you want to read
more about it click on a link below to
order his book shark in the housing pull
Matthew Cox thank you so much for coming
out I enjoyed listening to your story
you got a crazy ass story I got to tell
you that phenomenal story appreciate it
yeah a lot of us here glad I came what a
crazy story to think about the fact that
a Matthew Cox today could still happen
because the system's not strong enough
to prevent from that taking place
obviously he's got a incredible story
very entertaining story teller and see
in different perspectives of what he had
I want to hear your thoughts of today's
interview comment below as well as if
you haven't watched my interview with
Jordan Belfort the first time he and I
sat down together I think you would like
his perspective as well and if you
haven't watched a Mark Cuban interview
that I don't know four years ago five
years ago I think you'll enjoy this one
as well I do if you haven't subscribed
to the channel please do so thanks for
watching everybody take care bye-bye
you
[Music]